We've learned about the concise
syntax of arrow functions. We've
learned about the implicit
return of arrow functions. The
last thing we're going to learn
about and probably the most
important is that the fact that
this keyword does not get
rebound. What does that mean?
Let's show an example as to when
you might run into this. What I
have here is I've got this div
for the class of box right here.
When you click that box what's
going to happen is a two-stage
animation. You click it, and it
grows. Then it animates in these
words, from the left and from
the right. That's a two-stage
animation where the way it's
working is, I first add a class
of opening() to it. What that
does it actually grows it. Then
I add a class of open() to it,
which will bring in the letters
that have. Two stage of it's
always box and it has a class of
opening(), and then after a
couple of seconds I have a class
of open() being added to it.
Let's go ahead and code that up
here. I've given you all of the
CSS that comes along with it.
Nothing too exciting here, and
that's a whole another course
together. Essentially the way
it works is that when it has a
class of open(), I transform all
of those  in the
Twitter handle in. Then when it
has a class of opening(), I just
change the width and the height.
Then I've got transitions on
everything so it goes has some
funky effects. Let's go ahead
and do that. First thing I need
to do is open it up in a browser.
I click it and nothing works.
You can see the text is actually
there if I highlight it. We need
to select that element. I'm
going to say const box equals...
and why I use const there, just
because I don't ever want the
reference to this box to change
I use document.query.Selector()
and I'm going to select the box,
console.log() the box. Let's
make sure we're good to go there.
There we go. There is the box
being logged. Then we'll say
box to addEventListener(). We
want to wait for someone to
click it. Here we are going to
type a regular function. Why?
Let's take a look at why we're
going to do that. When someone
clicks it, let's console.log()
this. Click it. OK, it logs this
as equal to the box. This is the
thing then it got clicked on.
The way you can think about this
is you look at what got called
addEventListener() and you look
at the thing to the left of it,
the box. What's the box? That's
the div with the class of box()
that we ran. That's good. If you
swap this out with an arrow
function here, watch what
happens, window. Why do we get
window here? That's because
when you use an arrow function,
the value of this is not rebound
inside of that function. It is
just inherited form whatever the
parent scope is. What's the
parent scope of this? It's the
window. If you just go into your
console here and type this, this
is equal to the window, because
it's not being bound to anything.
It ends up by the window. You
don't just want to go willy-
nilly using arrow functions
everywhere, because it's just
last to type. You need to know
what are the benefits and the
downsides of it. In this case --
pun intended -- I don't want an
arrow function, because I need
the keyword to reference the
actual box that got clicked.
That would be even more
important if I had a whole bunch
of them. We can't use an arrow
function there. I'm going to
bring that back to regular
function. That's what we want.
You generally want these
functions for your top level
ones. Then inside of here, we're
going to say this.classList.
toggle(). We're going to toggle
opening(). Let's see how that
works. Good, it animates itself
in and out, in and out. Good.
After maybe 500 milliseconds or
so, I want to also toggle the
class of open(), because that's
the final stage. It's two stage
here. I think we'll use a
timeout for that. We'll set
timeout. You run a function
inside of there. We'll grab this.
classList.toggle(), open(). OK,
so does that work? See my dev
tools here click it. Good and
then, and no. Uncaught type
error cannot read property
toggle of undefined. That's
weird. It can't read toggle of
undefined. That means classList()
is not. How do I debug that? I
would go like this, console.log()
this.class List(). What is this.
classList() actually undefined.
It's nothing. Why is there no
classList() on the box? Let me
just console.log this and see
what we're dealing with, window.
Why do we have window showing up
here. If this right here was
equal to the box, why the same
hell is this not equal to the
box here? That's because we've
entered a new function, and this
function has not been bound to
anything, which means that, if
it's not bound to anything, it's
going to be equal to the window.
That's a pain in the ass.
People would do things like
these. You've probably done this
for instance like var self
equals this and now you have
this self variable. You can go
in here and say self.classList.
toggle open(). Try to get that
out. That's works, but not the
greatest, because we have this
weird or some of you like to say
var that equals this and etc.
Fortunately, we don't need to do
that anymore if I bring that
back to this. What we need to do
is just simply make it an arrow
function. Why? Because when you
have an arrow function, it does
not change the value of this. It
inherits the value of this from
the parent. We don't have to
worry about the scope changing
or anything like that. We can
just go ahead and keep working
using this as if it was scoped
to this actual function here,
just great. I'm going to leave
that console.log() in and I
should probably put 500
milliseconds in here. There we
go. Then after 500 milliseconds
it will animate itself
. Click it
again and it closes. That's a
little bit funky. I'm going to
fix this to be a little bit
nicer. None of this has
anything to do with arrow
functions. If you're interested
in seeing how I might figure
this out, you can stay on with
me. The problem with this right
here is that when you toggle an
open(), it adds a class of
opening(). Then after 500
milliseconds it adds a class of
open(). When you close it down,
you want it to be the opposite.
The way I would probably solve
this is first make two variables.
I'm going to use let and I'll
explain why in seconds. I would
say let first equals opening()
and let second equals open().
Then I'll take this first, and
I'll replace it with that. I'll
take my second, replace it right
there. I'm just using variables
we'll probably still have this
problem. We'll solve this weird
problem where it animates in the
wrong way. What I want to do is
I'm going to say, if this.
classList.contains() the first...
if it already contains opening()
that's because it's already in
an open state. If it already
contains it, opening(), because
it's in the open state, then we
want to switch the order of what
this happens. I'm just going to
switch the first and the second
variables. This is going to look
forward into our destructuring
exercise, but little hot tip. If
we want to switch two variables
with ES6 you can simply do this.
First, second equals second,
first. That will just switch the
values. Then first will be equal
to open(), and second will be
open to opening(). Then they
will close in the opposite order
that they've been opened. Let's
check this out. Bring it in,
bring it out, close it down.
Cool, a fun little animation
that we've made there. Big thing
we want to take home here is
that we can use an arrow
function for things inside of a
normal function and it's going
to inherit the value of this.